joke lat fox sports lead college
football analyst and this Saturdays in
Ann Arbor for Indiana at Michigan and
next weekend he's on the call for
Michigan at Ohio State noon Eastern
what's up guys look at you how you doing
look at you
look at you guys doing out here on the
west coast early wake up some warm
weather what do you think I can't
believe you've gone soft though Oh like
Charmin man I am soft as it can be oh
there's no doubt where did you grow up
right outside of Denver right between
Boulder and Denver in a town called
Arvada Colorado and then you go to see
you yes I played a couple years of minor
league baseball then I go back to see
you cold weather never bothered me right
I mean that's that's where I grew up I
played in it and now I moved out here
and I've been in the LA area for about
five and a half years and I am soft what
happened I tell you man your blood thins
out okay last weekend so I go we did
Ohio State Michigan State last week so
I'm at Michigan State and I always go
down on the field just because you can
get some great info right before the
game everybody's guards down so you can
finally get the injury info that you
really need right before the game you
know I mean you know this you've been on
fields and everything and I go down
there and I'm like I can't stay down
here any longer I haven't seen Marc
Dantonio or Urban Meyer but like I can't
do it anymore I've got to get back up to
the booth and jinney tapped our sideline
reporter does a marvelous job she's from
Minnesota she looks at me shakes her
shakes her head and was like you are
really soft and that's when I knew it's
official right like I'm super so gone
Holly I know I know Lisa I got good hair
you're probably vegan you're probably I
have not done that no I can't do that
Gus tried to do that last year am i
outing him that's all right Gus tried to
go vegan Gus Johnson yeah and so quick
story real quick we're at Texas Tech
doing a game Oklahoma State Texas tag
and Gus was trying to be vegan and and
you know I mean it was going okay there
was some cheese on some dishes and so we
you know we let it go as a crew we're
like are you gonna tell them you're
gonna tell them
don't tell him don't tell him and
finally they brought some Qdoba for us
at halftime and he had ordered the tofu
burrito but I look at the burritos
enlike every one of these is a chicken
burrito and so he takes a big bite into
it and then he kind of looks at me he's
like oh man ten days vegan I was like I
brought this stat up to the Dan that's
the last the least amount of time spent
trailing this season so Alabama for one
minute and 10 seconds do you know who's
second on the list least amount of time
trailing this season I would I would
guess either Washington State or Clemson
Clemson is fourth Notre Dame is second
Notre Dame Wow Utah State is third how
about the Aggies at home toss state by
the way Matt Wells is gonna get a big
job he's their head coach he's done a
marvelous job so watch out for that if
you're a team that's going through a
coaching transition I think a name that
you're gonna be surprised to be in the
mix is Matt wells the Utah State head
coach biggest opening that you think
we'll have next the offseason um I I
love him to death but I do think USC is
gonna come open I like clay Helton a lot
but I think USC is gonna go through a
change I don't think it will it's
something that's so expensive it is
known as the president yeah you got
drama that's off the football field
there yes you know other things to worry
exactly and and the budget will be an
issue with that and listen I hope clay
can can stick around I think he's a
really good football coach that maybe
didn't do his best job hiring a staff in
this first iteration as a permanent head
coach and I think if he can fix that in
particular from a recruiting perspective
that he can work he's a really good
football man and he was the adult in the
room that they needed at the time in
which he was hired but boy that was
about I mean 15 14 at home the Cal
that's a that's a tough pill to swallow
yeah you can't and I'm gonna go to the
UCLA game it'll be a good one
No UCLA's better telling you chips gonna
work out I feel better right but do you
think that this happened with Chip Kelly
that he was
this great innovator and then everybody
took what what he invented and so now
there's no novelty to Chip Kelly anymore
there is no novelty you're exactly right
especially at the college level and in
fact you can make the argument that he
is actually going in a little different
direction than a lot of the college
offenses have done because he's
incorporating some of and a lot of what
he did in the National Football League
but what happened at UCLA this year was
that chip ran into a culture that he
wanted to change 180 degrees and now
granted a lot of that is him and that's
his MO and that's what he did in
Philadelphia which is what rubbed a lot
of people the wrong way
but he had to run off about seventeen
guys that would have been on the too
deep this year I'm not talking about
graduation I'm talking about two deep
players for this year so they were so
thin that you could see why they would
struggle early in the year but I think
moving forward they're going to be at
least in the next two and three years
they're gonna be the best team in that
South Division very quickly is Jeff
Brohm gonna stay at Purdue or would he
go to Louisville um if I would you take
I would not go to Louisville over Purdue
I mean look what he's been able to
achieve at Purdue wait for a I had to
say it this way wait for a real blue
blood job Louisville is not a blue blood
job right now look at the drama that
they're in off the field their largest
donors getting pulled off the state I
don't want to get involved in that mess
at Louisville if I'm Jeff Brohm brahms
the type of guy that I think in this
class of head coaching changes will be
the top two or three candidate at almost
any school that changes over so I would
wait I would wait to see what the
Cowboys do I would wait to see if they
went after Lincoln Riley at Oklahoma cuz
Jeff Brohm is a guy that I think could
get a blueblood job and not just I know
he's from Louisville but I think I think
there are better jobs out there for for
Jeff Brown if you're Lincoln Riley and
let's say the Cowboys comes open yeah
Cleveland's gonna be open yep and you
could stay at Oklahoma listen I'm a
college guy I would stay at Oklahoma
here's my argument is that the NFL
doesn't pay any better than what
colleges are paying you know I mean
Lincoln Riley's making in four and
three-quarter million right now that's
gonna ratchet up over the course of his
current contract
can make an argument that if he finds
his way into the playoff he's gonna sign
a deal that's gonna rival Jimbo Fisher's
at Texas A&M and get an extension along
those lines at oh you he's in complete
control of that program and that
conference right now and I think he
could stay there for ten or fifteen
years plus you get control and every one
of these guys is in control free that's
right go to the NFL you're not gonna be
in control in Dallas no no especially in
Dallas now I think Denver might go after
Lincoln if Denver comes open something
about where they're at with their
quarterback and with the way that Elway
has made some decisions over the last
few years I could see them targeting
Lincoln Riley and going after a young
quarterback in the draft and trying to
mirror what the Rams have done over the
last few years with Sean McVeigh and and
Jared Goff but if I was Lincoln Riley I
would stay you can be a toe you with
full control for 10 or 15 years dan
that's with these numbers that's 70 75
million dollars I mean that's that's a
tough deal is Urban Meyer coaching Ohio
State in two years two years gosh I
would flip a coin on that next year I
would say very good chance that he's at
Ohio State I don't think that he's gonna
allow this to be his last ride
I think he's got too much pride he's
accomplished too much in the college
game and really at Ohio State for this
to be his last ride I think he'll
absolutely be back next year but then
what happens after that I'm not sure
that's when I would flip a coin I had an
NFL scout who said then and he's he's
starting the process of looking at these
chairs and she said he saw more players
on Ohio State try to protect themselves
for the draft than any other team this
year that he and I said well what do you
mean he goes you've got guys who were
junior eligible and it said this isn't
just Bosa but Bosa did do that but he
thinks there's other players on this
Ohio State team who are playing sort of
to protect themselves yeah they know
they have to play this season to get to
the NFL it's interesting that I've
talked with a couple of Scouts and
they've brought that up and and candidly
I don't see it and the reason is is I
don't think there is talented
they've been over the last couple of
years now I don't think there's as many
guys for Ohio State that are locks for
the NFL like we've seen over the last
few years did you know in the last three
years just off their defense alone
they've had 15 top four round picks
that's an insane number it's astonishing
only Alabama is churning out players
like that LSU maybe Clemson as well but
this iteration they're young on defense
their offensive line is not very good I
don't see a real pro prospect up front
maybe outside of their size
I think Dewayne Haskins needs another
year so I don't think he should come out
as a quarterback and I don't think that
the quarterbacks are excuse me wide
receivers are protecting themselves so I
actually think Ohio State this year is
probably the weakest they've been in
quite some time when it comes to pure
prospects for this year's NFL Draft and
you got Michigan coming to town and we
keep talking about Michigan being back
you're not back if you're Michigan until
you beat Ohio State yeah you're exactly
right so this doesn't matter
yeah like Jim Harbaugh this is the year
you have to beat Ohio State and that's
it this is what he was brought back for
right I mean he yes he wanted to be that
Michigan wanted to be back in the
conversation at the top end of college
football yes that's absolutely certain
and they weren't that for what was at
the seven years between Lloyd Carr and
and Jim Harbaugh but that's all well and
good you got a beat Ohio State you know
you ask any of you ask Mack Brown and
Bob Stoops about their tenure at Texas
and Oklahoma would what would they say
yeah it's great to win the conference
you got to beat that team and so in this
season with a team that's gonna be
favored on the road he's got to win this
game I mean next week is gonna be
massive Gus and I and Jenny will be
there and it I can't think of a more
important game that Jim Harbaugh has
coached since the Superbowl it's Alabama
bad for college football I don't think
that they are I get this question a lot
Dan maybe I'm maybe I'm a front-runner
I actually think sports in general are
better with dynasties those leagues are
better with dynasties I thought that the
NBA of the 80s was fantastic because of
magic
I thought that the MBA under Jordan was
phenomenal because of Michael Jordan
winning six titles and was not
entertaining you're talking about guys
who are entertaining I mean other than
is New England entertaining I think
there's a fascination there you're
watching the greatest quarterback of all
time they're not as predictable I could
see how Obama is predictable they're
they're predictably consistent they've
been ranked at some point number one in
the AP poll and every year for the last
nine years that's a record did you know
that since 2009 Alabama has spent more
time at the number one spot in the AP
poll than all of college football they
are right now the tiger versus the field
of 2000 you know but Tiger was
entertaining but golf was fantastic into
that Alabama is not in entertaining oh
man I it's not must-see TV
I mean I love I think - is there more to
tennis year because of him yeah but
you're just not there's no TuneIn factor
there when I watched Oklahoma when they
dominated they were they were fun desert
and fun to watch yes like I'd rather
watch Oklahoma than Alabama sure I
there's just an entertainment yeah and
Golden State is a bully but Golden
State's entertaining there's there was a
line rick reilly wrote an article about
tiger and Phil way back I can't remember
when it was published but he said that
basically Tigers boring and Phil is so
great because he's like watching a drunk
chase a balloon next to a cliff and I
feel like that's the Oklahoma versus
Alabama do you remember that line that
line has always stuck with me cuz it's
just such a great road scription chasing
a balloon by a cliff near a cliff that's
oh you right there the drunk chasing a
balloon near a cliff because it's like
their defense might give up 60 so it's
like what are they gonna do and Bama is
the consistent save your par but I love
watching that I was a guy that when I
watched baseball I love 2 to 1 verses 9
to 8
yeah so I might be the wrong guy to ask
yeah it's not that I understand what
you're saying about we should appreciate
greatness when we see it but I think
when you look at dynasties like there
has to be an
entertainment value attached to that
wouldn't you I would make like Mary's
what was her problem with the Spurs they
were boring or they were boring and you
know maybe the the worst part about
Alabama is that with all due respect to
Clemson there hasn't been the faux yeah
right like Alabama place Notre Dame this
year oh yeah I mean they're gonna
they're gonna trounce like they're gonna
be a double-digit favorite against
probably anybody or they're gonna be a
double-digit favorite versus everyone
but Clemson and the Clemson line will be
somewhere in the seven-and-a-half range
I final question and I you know it's the
most important question I'm gonna ask
you I want you to be honest okay I'll be
humble Oh better hair oh you or Kirk
Herbstreit
oh my bear my hair is better than the
Kirk I mean listen I don't know let me
go around the room here Paulie and look
I I don't know if I've ever put you on
the spot like this I'm to work with Kirk
I don't want it he's fantastic
right and he like paved the way for guys
like me by the way I owe my entire
career to a guy like Kirk and he's he's
phenomenal but you can't be considered
to have great hair unless it's over half
an inch long man they're shots fired any
chance
Kirk cut it short to take it easy on the
new guys I mean he's it's good
he's a good looking dizzy he's kind of
like you know when Brad Pitt will ugly
himself up just to like give you a
chance like sure
like he doesn't Kirk still I think that
Herbstreit is just I mean I need that
like you know like I can't have a little
bit longer here I think it's him saying
I'm gonna be taken seriously as an
analyst I don't want to be just you know
right a meat pie kid I can't just I
can't be this beautiful guy and and you
take I get it amis okay taking herb
straight over Joel clad chair no but I
want to say that you get lost and you
get lost in Herbstreit size though get
up to the air okay
I put on toes here no no I see what
you're doing here I see what you're
doing
that's another that's a trick listen you
go blue
Jordan LeBron say play to your strengths
okay think about the half-inch
prerequisite right I mean this be
considered you got great hair like he
can be beautiful but just if you're just
talking about the hair like I mean the
half-inch you gotta be over a half if
her streets watching right now her be
what's up man okay no I think
something's up and that quote reads a
lot different then it's over one trait
you you're better at than her be right
who's a better quarterback I mean I'll
just go to the numbers let's just
default of the numbers okay but you
played at Colorado he played at Ohio
State what are you trying to say we have
a national championship
yeah like 1990 yeah it was a great year
um I'll have state to one one since then
that's true that's true
this here's why I will forever be
indebted to Kirk Herbstreit because he
made it he made it okay into college
level to be a lead analyst without being
a Heisman Trophy winner you know so
because of that I'll forever being dead
but I threw for a lot more yards
you got that claps numbers there yeah
forty-six touchdowns in four years for
Joel Klat and seventy seven hundred
yards at Colorado no that's not bad
thanks Dan no I mean it I mean it's not
great it was a different era you know
I'd love to play for Lincoln Riley now
if I could play for the Lincoln Riley I
would be like the best backup because I
wouldn't actually play for you got
Herbstreit numbers at Ohio State I don't
wanna besmirched
legend and it's like five touchdown
passes in his career at Ohio State
Kirk Harry he's a better runner though I
think a baby's gonna default to the
numbers I'm sure he was all right listen
he's man he's a handsome guy yes
you just give me the hair in the numbers
right I'll give you Brian I'll give you
that nice joke lad he will be in Ann
Arbor it's Indiana at Michigan and then
he'll be in Columbus the following week
with yes sir
at Ohio sir I might I'm gonna go uh come
on up I don't want to do that
why are you come on well maybe I'll do a
drive-by maybe I'll do a drive-by it's
gonna be cold and on the load oh I'm
from Ohio
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]